let's talk football Super Bowl 57
bringing huge crowds to Arizona this
week the big game along with a PGA Golf
Tournament is expected to attract about
a million people to the Phoenix Arizona
area it will take a massive security
effort to keep all those visitors safe
over the weekend our Chris Van Cleave
got an inside look at the preparations
that law enforcement are making on the
ground and in the air Chris good morning
flying in close formation over State
Farm Stadium Agents from Customs and
Border Protection are keeping watch over
the home of Super Bowl Sunday where
security is already tight and we can
respond you agents or officers that need
our assistance in just minutes left
alone for
[Music]
the area around the stadium will be off
limits to other aircraft and drones on
the ground a small army of private
security and police are on the job
around the clock at least two dozen
agencies State local and federal are
providing Crews and resources including
nearly a thousand officers five miles of
fencing and two million pounds of
concrete barriers are already in place
right now there is no specifically
credible threat Scott Brown is the
homeland security special agent in
charge for Arizona he says about half
the security measures are things fans
will never see everything going into the
stadium gets screamed be that people be
that Goods you know be that the
merchandise that's going in to be sold
including the foods teams have been
assigned to cyber security others have
already seized counterfeit Super Bowl
merchandise everyone everyone have a fun
safe time you're that eye in the sky
exactly exactly that watchful eye
circling from above before during and
after the big game for CBS mornings I'm
Chris Van Cleave flying over Glendale
Arizona